uh
how often have i heard that eisen onion
iron union that's what the fans chant
for their club here in east berlin
let me tell you it's not an ordinary
club
i used to play in the stadium
okay at that time there were fewer
spectators
but the atmosphere was always amazing
i'm pascal i'm a former onion player and
today a sports reporter for kickoff
i want to explain what makes onyon so
special and when my time here came to an
end
for me it all started 10 years ago on
this piece of artificial turf my first
training session since then a lot of
things have changed
for example this gymnasium behind me
didn't exist
but there's one thing that hasn't
changed
in all sorts of colors things were
different then
things have developed it wasn't always
easy for you players
a lot of you came from work and some had
to go to school i still remember that
and the changing rooms were always a
mess
the changing rooms zoozy's domain
she's been working at onion for 20 years
she deals with all the everyday concerns
the youngsters face
and makes sure they get the clothes they
need
susie is the heart of the club
because i helped a lot with the building
up of the youth system this became my
life
that's the only way to put it
nowadays it really is my life and i like
it i like to be with the youngsters i
like being here
and you're someone they can talk to the
second mom
yes and there are players who say hey
mom how are you so we have that too and
it amuses us a bit
but i do think they kind of like me
susie even did my laundry for three
years i took to the pitch as a defender
for onion going up against bundesliga
players to be like kevin and jerome
boateng
but they are the exceptions
just a couple of players from a
bundesliga used team gopro one or two a
year
i lacked the necessary drive the
absolute will to do it my studies were
more important to me and so i left union
behind
of course the fans can't imagine life
without onyon on matchdays they meet up
here at the local bar right next to the
stadium
the place is also a little museum
the walls are covered in history
refounded in east germany in 1966
underdogs on yeon always had to fight
for survival
they were always an anti-establishment
club
and drew in freethinkers to their fan
base
their arch enemy was bfc dynamo berlin
the favorite club of the stasi the east
german secret police
it's a fierce rivalry to this day
andrea's witnessed it all he's been an
unknown fan as long as he can remember
he even saw me play
andreas knows this club better than
anyone
meinhardt ins calacon
hedmut kyle
wolfgang hillman for the co-trainer here
young stop he is walking on your
dictionary
you've been coming for 40 years what's
so fascinating about this club
what's fascinating is it's always been
the same theme munon never really played
successful football but you had 90
minutes of power in the house there was
constant chanting of eisenhunyon it got
to the opponents we definitely didn't
always have the best players but our
team spirit was extreme
extreme
bonyon fans stick together
during christmas season they even meet
up in the stadium to sing christmas
carols
no football necessary
and when it comes to their stadium they
are not afraid to get their hands dirty
the rundown alte first array was
renovated entirely by the fans
they volunteered their services as well
as painters and diggers to save the club
some money and then by the thousands
they even bought shares of their new
stadium
it was a feeling of togetherness the
baker from kaepernick brought the rules
the ice cream man came by there'd never
be that kind of togetherness anywhere
else every club ought to go through that
for a year every day there were 30 or 40
construction workers there it wasn't
easy sometimes it was 20 degrees and
sometimes 20 below
i think that's unique at least in europe
or maybe even in the football world
fans are very proud of it just like
today every bundesliga stadium changes
its name every two or three years the
out to first july will still be the out
to first arrive 30 years from now and
we're proud of that hardly any club can
claim that
things are different at onyon
i noticed that right away back in the
day
they cheer for the players even after a
boring scoreless draw
the relationship between the fans and
the team is an especially close one here
but i'm not a part of that anymore or
onyon is no longer a part of me
why is that
is it my profession my journalistic
distance
at the end of the day i'm no longer a
fan
i'm a critical observer of this
overhyped business of football
the club has now established itself in
the bundesliga second division
i'm not the only one who's changed
as well
i remember sebastian brunich from the
old days when he was a fans favorite and
a hero of the club's promotion
today he is an assistant coach here
and on is a matter of the heart for him
i've got a one-year-old brother who also
played football at some clubs in the
west
i witnessed often enough that they were
booed out of the stadium and insulted
after playing badly
i hardly ever experienced that here here
sometimes we had a lot of really bad
games
sometimes so bad you couldn't watch them
the people here always stand by the club
and the team
that is really exceptional and it's
still like that now
identification is a big word you have to
live it you have to feel it
every person who works for the team
sacrifices him or herself for the work
and the players have to do that too
of course it's professional football
nowadays players come and go but we're
trying to keep the youth here grounded
so that they appreciate what they have
here
i also appreciated my time at unyon and
always gave my all as a player
in the end i chose a different path
but they stayed here sebastian brunich
and fans like andreas
and the carer susie
it's the people who make onyon so
likeable
a club which is a part of my history
and one which you don't forget so easily
that's why it's aizan onyon
iron union